okay let me quickly introduce myself for
those of you that don't know me
um my my name is michael shaw
i am currently the general manager of uh
aws glue and aws lake formation
uh these are two uh web services on the
aws platform
and uh you know my brief history prior
to this i was a
i was a an entrepreneur a co-founder of
a company called amiado
um that was doing etl in the cloud and
then prior to that
i was a database researcher uh writing
papers and publishing at places like
vldbn
and sigma and so on i've been in the
data space
my all my entire career and today
what i'm going to share with you is what
we see or what i'm seeing
um at aws
what i see is happening in the data
warehousing industry
and how it's evolving what we see our
customers doing
instead of using data warehouses they're
instead building data lakes
sort of a new paradigm for organizing
all your data in your company
and i'll be spending a lot of time today
talking about lake formation and how
lake formation makes it easier to build
data lakes
um at the same time you know please feel
free to ask questions
as we go along i'm going to leave about
15 minutes at the end of this talk
to you know to kind of discuss
what we see and answer any questions
that you have but
feel free to try to keep this
interactive okay
okay great so quickly uh
the today i'm going to go over four
things first motivate why
our customers are actually building data
lakes uh describe to you what we mean by
a data lake
i'll tell you a little bit about why
it's hard to build a data lake
and then show you a little bit of um or
sort of
a taste of lake formation and the
technology behind
lake formation that makes building data
lakes much easier than it was before
and we have a lot a lot more to go and
i'll close the talk
by talking about some of the key sort of
research
opportunities that we have in this
community to help advance
this evolution or revolution that's
happening in the data wearing
warehousing industry
so you'll probably know this because
you're attending um
you know you're attending vldb um
but about 25 30 years ago
this is how companies used to organize
all of their data
they did all of their decision-making
decision making
um based around based on the data that
they had in their enterprise data
warehouses they were building these big
analytic databases and they were feeding
these databases
uh with data from a bunch of structured
databases
um operational databases that recorded
their transactions
um you know the what was going on with
their customers what was going on
you know with their employees and so on
they get all this data into a
centralized place called the enterprise
data warehouse through a process called
etl
extract transform and load you'd spend a
bunch of time designing a unified schema
uh maintaining that schema over time it
would take months
but then you'd get your enterprise data
warehouse up and running
and once you had it up and running you
know you'd use
business intelligence tools uh to
analyze that data
and for the most part um you do a little
bit of ad hoc analysis
a lot of reporting and this data was
feeding decisions that
our c-level ex c-level executives made
in in organizations to optimize or
change
the strategy or um you know build new
products around their business
okay well since then a lot of years have
passed and many things have changed
the biggest thing that has changed or
you know evolved
is the data in particular the data that
people want to analyze in their company
no longer fits inside of a data
warehouse and here's what i mean by that
first there's a lot more data that
companies are collecting than people
think
it turns out as we kind of look over our
customer base the amount of data
the companies are storing is growing
about
10x every five years and most of that
data is untapped
it's dark it's not actually put into a
data warehouse
and so if you're thinking about you know
building a data data platform in your
organization
you're thinking about building a
platform once every decade decade and a
half
and so if it's got to live about 15
years
that data platform has to scale three
orders of magnitude
and that's a long way to go okay
and data warehouses are no longer
scaling um
the data no longer fits it's too big and
so it's not
no longer cost effective to put into a
data warehouse
the other thing that's happening is that
the data is much more diverse
we're not just putting structured data
into these databases but you've got
machine data network logs um
social networking feeds iot logs
semi-structured data unstructured data
research articles and so on
and those things don't actually fit
because data warehouses are really
designed around structured data
another pressure that we see in
organizations is that
it's not just the c-level executives but
there's a lot more people
whose job it is to analyze that data
you've got line of business users that
want to optimize their products
you know product managers that want to
see what's going on with their customer
base
you have devops folks that want to do
debugging of their distributed
applications
uh you've got business analysts uh
they're looking for opportunities to
optimize
various aspects of their business data
scientists
that are looking to build uh predictive
models
and you know the kinds of analyses as i
said
are changing it's just not sql analytics
anymore but people want to do machine
learning
real time streaming analyses for fraud
detection or
event detection and also scientific
analyses
and then the world also around us have
changed in the last 25 years
because now that there's a lot more data
out there
people want to democrat you know not
only do you want to democratize access
to to that data across your organization
but you also have to comply with a
number of regulatory requirements
either you know from the government so
privacy requirements like
gdpr or ccpa that says hey you've got to
forget
you our customers have a right to have
all their records deleted from your
systems
to other kinds of requirements that are
there in the industry like
hipaa fedramp soc and you know there's
hundreds of these that that you can go
get and these are at
odds with one another in terms of being
able to give people access to their data
versus making sure that that data only
gets you know into the right hands
and so all of these things that people
want to do with their data
are just not that easy to do with a data
warehouse or a collection of data
warehouses
and so this is where data lakes in
particular the cloud
and building data lakes on the cloud
has come into play
customers what we see customers do is
take all their various data silos
whether it be an operational database a
nosql database
um you know a data mart we see them
unblocking a lot of their silos
or unlocking a lot of their silos and
pouring their data into
a centralized storage system a cloud
storage system like amazon s3
why because it's there it's ubiquitous
it's low cost it's cheap and
it's highly durable and highly available
okay
and so what that means is you actually
now have the ability to centralize
all of your data assets across your
entire organization
and prior to this you'd have to build
your own data center manage your own
file systems and stores and scale them
and at some point
you just didn't have the expertise to do
it anymore relying on the cloud now this
can actually happen
the other thing that the cloud allows
you to do is you know pick any engine
that you want
you're not stuck with just one data
warehouse or one type of data warehouse
or one type of analytics
um you know we have for example amazon
redshift which is our
which is our data warehouse in the cloud
amazon's data warehouse in the cloud
we also have in amazon athena for doing
sql analytics over your data lake
directly we have a quick site for doing
bi
um business intelligence sagemaker for
ml
emr for doing big data analysis and
these things can be spun up
as you need as you go there is no
upfront investment that you have to pay
for and
kind of you know maintain over time
and so now the question you know the
question that arises is
how are you going to actually manage
this entire thing on your cloud
infrastructure how are you going to make
sure that the right data
is accessed by the right people through
the right engines
what is that single locus of control
going to be and how are you going to
organize all of this so that you can
actually
um you know make all that stuff work
together how do you multiplex this data
and um and that's really what the data
lake is about
that's really what you know the
activities or
the the things that you have to do to go
build a data lake it's all about it's
not just about pouring data into a
single place
so what is a data lake it's it's a new
information hub
it's no long you know it's no longer the
enterprise data warehouse but it's a new
information out
that companies that we see companies
building for
doing all of their decision making and
and
analytics um it's a centralized secure
repository and it's important to
to stay secure because of all the
government regulations that are out
there
[Music]
and also company regulations that are
out there allows you to govern discover
share and analyze both structured and
unstructured data at any scale
and we've got a number of companies i
think more than 10 000 companies
building data lakes on aws more than
anywhere else
and here's sort of a small selection of
those companies
and a number of them also are using late
formation to actually build their data
lakes
on aws now i don't want this to be just
an advertisement for late formation
but i do want to kind of point out that
these companies are getting tremendous
value out of lake formation
there are three main things that they're
saying one it's a one-stop shop for
building your data lake
it simplifies your access your your
ability to
to set up access controls for all the
data assets in your company
and it makes it super easy to ingest and
clean that data
and that's sort of roughly the three
things that
that that lake formation does for you so
before i go into
and dig deep into lake formation let me
tell you a little bit about what's hard
about building data lakes
and i'll tell you about how lake
formation makes it easier
so we all know this cleaning your data
takes uh takes a lot of time people talk
about this eighty percent of the work
goes into cleaning what people don't
often talk about
is you know how hard it is to actually
secure your data
which is which is what we've seen you
know throughout our you know throughout
our
our ecosystem in our customer base
here are the typical steps of building a
data lake um
each of these steps actually are done by
different personas
the first step is in sort of preparing
your data so it can actually be analyzed
the ingestion and cleaning phase you're
going to extract data you're going to
set up storage
um sort of landing area for your data in
s3
and then you're going to go through the
hard hard you know job of making sure
that that data
is in a form that you can analyze it or
build machine learning models or do
inference on it and typically today data
engineers do this work
what we don't often talk about in this
in this
community is the amount of work that it
takes to actually secure your data
um data stewards are typically
responsible for this and what they're
doing is they're deciding what data
products are going to be in these data
lakes and who's going to be able to
access them
and how they're going to be able to
access them and what we're finding is
that the mechanisms that are out there
for securing your data
and sharing that data effectively or
cost effectively
they're just not not really well thought
out and ends up
uh you know causing a bunch of overhead
both in terms of storage and maintenance
then the third you know thing that
people want to do with their data lakes
is just use it
and this is where the data analysts and
the same scientists come in
so it's hard to build these data lakes
because you actually have to
you know and build a system for um
making it easy to build data
data lakes because you've got to
actually serve multiple personas
let me tell you what you know what what
it looked like before lake formation
so if you're on aws if you're trying to
build a data lake you need to get to
your sources
here's an example of a you know of a
screenshot of all the sources
that somebody has in their account for
their databases these are sql databases
postpress databases mysql databases
oracle and so on
you locate those databases you got to
figure out a place to put the data
so you set up landing areas inside of
inside of s3 now you got to set up
access policies on who can access these
you know
these landing areas now you really you
know the consumer of this data really
wants to think about
data sets as collections but the
policies
and the way you kind of express these
things
really are focused around the bits and
bytes of how you organize these things
inside of you know
your object store system so in this case
it's how you organize it in s3 with an
object
um and who gets to access a single
object or who gets to access a bucket
or a list of buckets and so don't they
don't very map very well or very easily
um you know to the collections that you
want to think about like here's my
database coming from
sales or here's my database that's
coming from you know my iot devices
and there's all kinds of limitations on
how big these policies can get
then you've got to go and actually map
all this stuff to some kind of data
model
we actually give you a data catalog glue
is the service that does that it's one
of the services that i manage
and it has a data catalog inside of it
and you can actually create a data model
for all the data that's sitting inside
of s3 that's based on tables and
databases but you got to create it
and then you got to you know build an
etl flow that actually gets the data
from one place to another in this
particular case you're writing spark
scripts
you got to also protect your metadata so
you got to create metadata access
policies
again using the same json-like language
that we had
for s3 and then finally depending on the
service you're using to analyze the data
you've got to set up
users and access control for the service
in this case it's a terminal that you're
using to
access redshift which is a data
warehouse
now you've got to do this all over again
but depending on the data set the users
that you have or the end services that
you're
using and of course um
you know you're still not getting
exactly what you want um
the system that we had before was manual
error-prone
and time-consuming
and so here comes lake formation okay
it's a fully managed service that allows
the three personas that we talked about
data engineers data stewards and data
analysts
to build clean secure data lakes and
days
the lake formation is basically you know
the
if you will the locus of control
uh that helps you multiplex all this
data that's in s3
[Music]
to all the various engines that you
might want to use
to analyze that data and it offers
two main features one
for simplifying the ingest and cleaning
process okay
and there um you know underneath the
covers there's a bunch of different
primitives that you can use to make that
easier
i'll get into some of those in a second
and then the second big thing does is it
allows you to secure
access to your data in a centralized
place so you don't have to make
innumerable copies of your data when you
want to share it
and so that allows you to have cost
effective
sharing of your data in a secure way
according to your
governance and
your governance and um and industry
policies that you have
compliance policies like that
at the bottom of course is amazon s3
which is the ubiquitous
low-cost highly reliable data lake
storage system gives you eleven nines of
durability
all right um before i get into lake
formation let me just tell you about
some
some use cases um some things that we
were able to do with lake formation
and it kind of highlights um what
what the difference is between a data
lake and a data warehouse and
and why and why it's so powerful
um is my favorite example uh you know
we're all
going through um this sort of shared
experience across the world
in this pandemic of of trying to fight
covet 19
or at least try to stay away from the
disease
um a few months ago we decided in aws
that
you know even though we're not experts
in the disease
um we should try to help in some way
and so we put together basically a
grassroots efforts
um you know on basically on shoestring
budget which is
you know whoever wanted to help um to
put together a data lake
that has information uh relevant
information that
scientists experts health experts
could use to track
and track contain and fight the disease
and we sourced a whole bunch of publicly
available sources and
built a data lake around it so example
data sets that we have in there are
johns hopkins universities cases and
deaths data that you
all probably have already heard of and
looked at but we also have a hospital
bed availability
data data on research articles
on covid19 which are growing enormously
exponentially fast and also data
not just from healthcare institutions
and nonprofits but also from
um universities like carnegie mellon
that are trying to predict
um where uh you know where copenhagen
flare-ups will happen
uh through surveys and uh you know other
uh mech statistical analysis that
they're doing
and this is kind of you know typifies
what you would want to try to do with a
data lake that's kind of
that's very hard to do in a in a
warehouse-like environment
so for example imagine you wanted to see
you know what kind of therapies
were working well there's you know i
think
almost 50 or 40 to 50 000 research
articles in this data set that's there
by the allen institute
and if you're trying to look for a
particular you know therapy for example
um uh you know therapy for inhibiting
um a certain response um
you can actually you can actually do a
query against all of the metadata that's
there
but it's all in this sort of very
unstructured form and you know all the
key concepts haven't been pulled out
uh what we did is we showed that you
could actually use things like amazon
kendra from rml team
amazon comprehend medical to very easily
process this data
bring out the key words and then you
know run typical bi analysis to kind of
pinpoint the articles that are relevant
and then kind of dig in or just do you
know traditional search through kendra
to find relevant articles and then kind
of iterate on it
this is the kind of stuff that's hard to
do in a data warehouse
and the co you know take something like
this and try to make it available to the
entire world in a data warehouse
and uh and you realize that you know
it's it's
it's almost impossible you know you
can't have i think we have
you know more than tens and tens of
thousands of customers actually using
this data lake
you just can't have all of them using a
single data warehouse
and so this ability to kind of you know
automatically spin up
the engines that they need at the time
that they need
in this on-demand cloud environment
makes all of this possible
and so this really you know this really
is
very fundamentally different from what a
data warehouse is and people will say
isn't this just a
modern data warehouse i i think
qualitatively it's very different
okay and we were by the by the way with
late formation and the ability to kind
of
you know securely share this data and
what i mean by securely share this data
is that
you know you can get access to this data
without having to copy it in many
different ways because it's all public
data
we're able to set all this stuff up make
sure that all this curated data actually
gets into a single place
in a matter of days it took us literally
less than a week to set this up and
launch it
here's another example um this is a
company called nu skin
um what they wanted to do is just hide
pii data they're a healthcare company
uh from their scientists so that those
scientists could then you know do a
variety of analysis
uh rather than go into you know a bunch
of examples here the main point here is
that they were able to reduce their cost
by 40
um eliminate the amount of um
maintenance costs that they have by over
30 percent
um and you know the the advantages kind
of
go on and on let me kind of dig into how
lake formation works um lake formation
basically has two stacks
of of features um one
um stack of features really are around
doing ingestion it's on the left hand
side and it's actually built on aws glue
which is our etl service in the cloud
and then the other stack of features
is really around security and cloud
security search
and um and sharing and collaboration
okay the cool thing is this is all built
on blue
and glue is serverless so all the
components that you have you never have
to actually spin up a machine
um the main components that i think you
need to work
worry about for this talk in blue are
the data catalog
which gives you a centralized place for
managing the metadata for your entire
data lake
and that's how we're going to actually
manage all the security policies
on the data lake and then
it's good they're going to be intro
that's how we're going to model the data
and then and manage the security
policies on the daily
and then the serverless etl component
that allows you to actually do a lot of
the ingest
without ever having to um configure a
machine
i'm gonna walk through an example really
quickly to show you how all of this
stuff works
um and for each of the individual
personas
so let's start with the data engineer to
get started
data engineer basically can use these
standard blueprints that we have to
start to
start ingesting data the first thing
they did they do is they tell
information you know where their data
lake is going to be or stored or managed
in s3
they just basically give us a bunch of
permissions to go and manage that area
and then they kick off a blueprint um
it's a template
pretty simple that's what the name
implies and underneath the covers it
sets up a complex
workflow it's a dag of jobs
that allows you to extract the data from
a variety of sources
and organize it on s3 so that you can
run analytics quickly
so this includes things like
partitioning things like
[Music]
organizing all the metadata into the
data catalog
and setting up default policies in lake
formation on who can access it
and then because all of this stuff is
underneath the covers is just running
inside of glue
if you don't like what this template
creates you can of course go in and
customize it
um here's a screenshot of what it looks
like if you're trying to bring in data
from cloudtrail
cloudtrail is our service that tracks
every api call that a particular account
makes and people often analyze their
cloudtrail data for security
um violations or just to understand how
um
you know how their users are using their
accounts and
keep track of you know where the usage
is going
anyway we have a blueprint that allows
you to basically bring that
data instantly into your data lake
here's what it looks like underneath the
covers the sort of the comp
the myriad of complicated steps that you
need to take to get that data in there
all available at the touch of a button
and then you know while this is you know
being set up
[Music]
data engineers can also use a bunch of
different data cleaning transforms
that we that we offer the one the data
cleaning transform that i want to talk
about right now
is a data cleaning transform that allows
you to do deduplication
and the reason i want to talk about it
is you know it's not just
a bunch of you know pipes and and uh
and and bits uh that we're managing but
we're also
giving you state-of-the-art algorithms
to allow you to clean data these are
algorithms that we've created internally
within aws
um internally for amazon retail
that scale better than anything that's
out there in state of the art
so the the algorithm that i have um i
want to talk about today is find matches
that allows you to do deep duplication
across two large
data sets imagine for example you're
trying to merge
two catalogs here in this particular
case these are catalogs of shoes
as we all know um catalogs um
you know they they all have various sort
of uh
structured attributes like name and
price and so on
but the values in them can vary and
differ and in this particular case
we're looking at two different shoes of
uh from the same company
and it's actually the same same model um
it's a it's a saddler but they're named
differently in these two different
catalogs
they have similar um profile in terms of
price
they have so much similar profile in
terms of number of colors that they that
are supported here
and so you and i can look at this and
say it's the shane shoe
but if you try to encode this in an etl
process you might get it right the first
time but if you ever had to evolve it
it'd be very brittle and the set of
rules that you create um
you know would be really hard to
maintain and so this is sort of you know
a perfect candidate for for doing ml
and there's a bunch of people that have
gone out there and said hey look you
know we can
you know we can you're gonna run deep
learning on this or we can use you know
a variety of um ml models to go do this
it turns out none of them actually
scales
okay and the reason they don't all scale
is because and
you know at the end of the day our
customers want to come in
and you know they want to do
deduplication across billions of rows
for example healthcare records or um
you know quotes from various equities
and so on
and to do that you know the naive
approach here is you're going to look at
every pair of records
and that's just not going to work and if
you you know build one of these
these neural network models just takes
too long
so we've actually broken this process up
into sort of three different steps
so it's actually standard in the
literature um
three steps called uh blocking scoring
and partitioning
and we have innovations in each one of
these steps um the blocking step
basically says you know create subsets
of these
records um that you're going to consider
all pairs of and don't worry about
pairs of records across blocks because
they're unlikely to match
um and then what you're doing here is
actually looking for for records that
match that that are approximately the
same
you might do this for for record linking
you might do this for deduplication
then you're going to come up with some
kind of scoring function in this case
um we're going to create a scoring
function based on positive negative
examples
and then uh we're going to use a a new
sort of thresholding technique
to partition these scored pairs
into groups and those groups are going
to be the ones that are going to be
labeled
as duplicates or matches
i'm going to save you the the details on
the algorithm um i think you can read it
in the paper
we published it in 2018
um the important point here is that we
can gr we can
scale this algorithm uh to
to over now over a billion rows at that
time it was 400 million rows
finish it in about two and a half hours
in the previous state of the art
and took weeks and the
the partitioning ticking technique that
we're using not only
gives you too like an actual score and
confidence in how good your grouping is
um but it's actually pretty effective
without actually you know introducing a
lot of tuning knobs compared to the
previous state of the art
okay so that's uh that's the workaround
around
ingest and cleaning there's a whole
bunch of stuff that we've done to make
it simple
for people to share their data and
share it securely
the approach that we take is you model
your data in the data catalog as a
collection of
tables inside of databases and tables or
consist consists of columns
semi-structured data columns and rows
and then you specify access control
policies on that an
administrator is going to come in and
actually specify those policies
users are going to access this data not
directly but through a variety of
integrated services
we support athena which is a query
service
redshift to data warehouse emr big data
service
glue etl quick site bi
and we're adding more and more services
over time
they access the data by querying that
data through these cert these analytic
services
and then late formation basically
mediates the access to the underlying
data
and we actually have today a shared
responsibility model where the
engine actually uh participates
in the security and then the process of
securing that data
let me first tell you about you know the
kinds of features that we have in our
security so not only can you
control data access on individual tables
rather than thinking about individual
objects as three objects and buckets
but you also can control permissions on
a per on a per column
basis so you might have for example
products and their reviews
and you might not want to give user one
for example
access to the reviews and user to only
access to the columns
that talk about the product so in lake
formation you can come up with any
combination of these things for any
combination
of users the other nice thing about lake
formation is because all these accesses
go through a single
access point meaning they're all going
through a single set of apis
[Music]
for for for a single set of apis
sorry a single set of apis where um
where you get
access to the credentials for accessing
that data
we know who is accessing what and when
and so you can audit
all of the accesses for all the stuff
and all the data lakes that you have in
your account
okay it's also easy to see you know who
has permission to what because
these permissions are not spread across
many different engines
so here's how it works and so this is
the piece that i was stumbling stumbling
over in the previous um
in the previous slide you have a user
and typically the user is represented by
an i am role but you can also have
third-party identities coming in from
um identity providers like active
directory
they you know they're going to query a
table t um
somehow and the integrated services are
going to know that you know this user
wants to go and analyze this table to
you
the service on behalf of the user is
going to request access for the
underlying objects
like the actual s3 files that comprise
that table
lake formation is only going to give
back temporary credentials
these are just permissions to be able to
access that that data
and these are temporary they're scoped
in time and location so that
you know it's only for the duration of
the query
and then those credentials are used by
these engines to request those objects
and then the engines are actually going
to do the various filtering that you
need to drop the columns that are
necessary
and then do the computation return the
results okay
so this the the security is actually
shared
by the integrated service as well as
you know the underlying data store which
is s30
and this is unique um in the sense that
we don't have an intermediate
filtering fleet there's advantages and
disadvantages of this and we can talk
about it
but one of the advantages of this is of
course cost customers aren't really
spending a tremendous amount more money
over the
normal processing of your data and this
is what they like
here's some screens i'm running out of
time so i'm going to quickly go over
these screens but here's some screens on
how you can actually use lake formation
to specify
the permissions these permissions look
like standard grant and remote
permissions that you see in a database
you can do it at the column level and
then depending on
you know the analyst and what they're
able to see what these screens are
actually showing you is that
you know one analyst is able to see you
know a fraction of the columns in this
case they're
uh if you look on the screen shot on the
left hand side there's seven columns
that this analyst can see and
um you know there's another uh analyst
um that's gonna access it through a
different engine might see fewer columns
and then the data scientists can access
it through notebooks and and see all the
columns for example
except for pii yeah
you can also through our console
monitor all the use of that data lake
who's accessing what with all the
metadata so you have a centralized
affiliate place for
all your audit logs um so if you have a
compliance officer coming in and saying
hey who
accessed what in the past um you know in
the past
month or in the past year you can
actually give them a compliance audit
rather than trying to you know create
this manual yourself
and the other cool thing about this and
this is the piece that i think i want to
you know kind of spend a little time on
is once you get into the data lake world
it's no longer about you know a closed
world
uh you know where you're sitting inside
of a data warehouse
um in some ways you suddenly have an
open world
where you're sharing this data with not
just people within your organization but
you could possibly share this data
with other organizations um folks that
you may or may not trust with very
you know with varying levels of trust so
we recently for example
release cross account sharing so we have
customers sharing data that are coming
from different companies
through s3 without making a copy of that
data
um or should i say they eventually make
copies but at least for the sharing
purposes you don't have to make a copy
okay um and then and the cool thing is
that the
the database model for doing security
grants and revokes
is really nice it's a declarative model
and that declarative model allows you to
do things like delegate
access so you can give it to you know
you can delegate access to a table to
some
other account and that account can then
further delegate access to users inside
of their account
and that model just sort of naturally
works it's what uh it's what people want
and it was just harder to do in a lot of
the other security models that were
out there and so this is i think a win
for the database community
we kind of figured it out and got it
right and it seems to scale beyond just
data warehouses and databases
it's worth thinking about because you
can set up all kinds of interesting
topologies here
um there are many more features here
that make it easier for people to
discover data
and provide context around data in
particular
in late formation you can add metadata
that makes it easier to understand
what fields mean what database tables
are for
and eventually you know you can imagine
using these these tags if you will
to automatically secure your data
and so that that you know puts me into
this sort of last
you know slide of the talk which is you
know where
is this all taking us you know
everybody's building data lakes
you know we're just kind of following
our nose here in aws
um and what we you know what at least i
did and as
as part of our you know journey here is
back into this
and by the way all of this stuff is not
me building this it's really you know
the work of hundreds and hundreds of
people
in aws doing it but in terms of the
topic you know in my interests
i just kind of backed into it going from
data warehousing to data lakes
and it's actually just a it's a it's not
just a matter of an architectural change
right it's really a change in terms of
what's possible okay
and so the data warehousing industry is
now today is going
undergoing an upheaval um customers
don't want to be limited by data
warehouses
and so we need we came up with a new
name for it data lakes it might be
called something else in the future but
at the end of the day
it's about managing all your data sets
in a in a way where you have central
centralized locus of control
doesn't necessarily have to be in a
centralized location but that's
that's just you know that's just
practically useful in some cases
you have a centralized locus of control
and the question is
you know how do you want to enable
people
to share their data and this is becoming
more and more important
in many many different circumstances
and the two areas where we've started
exploring um
you know i think there's a lot of
opportunity for researchers in this
community to come in and help
and define uh you know what's going to
happen in this
in this evolution or in this revolution
the two areas that i i specifically kind
of pointed out is one is machine
learning now of course this machine
learning isn't something that you know
we came up with here
right i mean for the last 10 years it's
been undergoing a revolution
but this combination of you know machine
learning
to to help you manage data
not for the sake of actually learning
from data but just for the sake of
managing data
i think is is incredibly powerful and
has a lot of applications
um for example um you know what do you
you know what do you do if you want to
be able to automatically or a lot of our
customers say hey i want to i want you
to automatically detect sensitive data
and secure it
well that's great but what if the
machine learning algorithm doesn't do a
good job
you know and so in many cases you know
if it didn't do a good job
okay you know you call it precision
recall error and you move on
uh and you improve the algorithm in this
particular case if it didn't do a good
job
it could mean a leak of some some
valuable information
so um you know so is machine learning
even applicable in this context because
certainly our customers want it
people want to use machine learning to
help machine learning they want to
use machine learning to assess the
quality of their data so they can build
better models
and know when to you know rebuild their
models because the the data has drifted
they want to use machine learning to
help build etl flows
you know here's what my data ought to
look like here's what the source looks
like
can you do a gold directed auto cleaning
and transformation for me
i'm just kind of you know hitting the
tip of the iceberg here on some of the
topics that we see from our customers
then there's a whole bunch of you know
interesting possibilities that show up
around
sharing security and governance um today
i think
we have a tremendous amount of tools to
secure our data
to lock it down to encrypt it to hide it
to tokenize it okay those things that
are there
but what i what what if i want to
actually share that data
in a limited way and and we don't even
have actually vocabulary to even talk
about it
um and but but we see this coming up
over over and over again for example you
know all of these people that want to
share data
about kovid and uh you know it's it's
um its impact or its potential impact
um based on what they've gotten from you
know surveys or
you know healthcare studies that they've
done they want to share this data
without actually
you know revealing the identities of
users
and and we don't have a good set of
mechanisms
to sort of universally talk about this
and i think i think those things are
going to show up in the next 10 years
um then there's this question around
public data lakes
imagine you have a public data lake and
you have hundreds like today we have
hundreds of
of sources what if we get to thousands
or tens of thousands of sources in our
public data like how do people find the
relevant
sources and use them and then finally
you know an interesting problem that
that seemed to kind of
you know tip our fancy a little bit um
it service what came out of this
process is you know imagine you're
actually you know doing all this data
sharing
and somebody comes in and says you know
prove to me that that's your data
or prove to me that it's not your data
meaning that it actually came from you
know some public source
i mean you didn't you know make any
derivations of it
um i don't think we have good mechanisms
to even talk about this and
and and make those proofs and my call of
i just kind of made up a word
for it or a term for it called provable
prominence but i think these are the
kinds of things that our customers are
going to ask for in the future
and i would much rather be prepared with
with the vocabulary for doing these
kinds of things
instead of know just kind of figuring it
out on flying
so um this is where i think you know
people like you yourselves in the vldb
community
can come collaborate with us um
and help us out with that said uh i've
taken too much of your time i went a few
more minutes than i wanted to
um but thank you for listening and
i am happy to take questions